praise gabe getting your hands on a
steam deck is about to become a lot
easier plus you can play a bunch of new
old games on your nintendo switch all
this and more on today's gamespot news
with the end of june approaching and the
arrival of q3 steem put out a statement
that is going to make a lot of gamers
happy
for anyone that has a steam deck
reserved with a q3 fulfillment period
listed the first batch of emails to that
group will be going out on june 30th
before the next quarter has even begun
what's more the company also confirms
that it is increasing steam deck
production shipping out more than double
the amount of units it was previously
that means if you are in that q3 bracket
you are more than twice as likely to
receive an email than say me when i had
my q2 order i would say i was jealous
but what do i have to be jealous about
i already got my steam deck day number
102 without a steam deck
i'm starting to give up hope
how else am i supposed to play pc games
without this thing
to prepare for your handheld's arrival
remember that steam's summer sale is
happening until july 7th so make sure to
check it out for any games you plan to
play on deck as well as gamespot.com for
the best deals you can find moving from
the portable pc to its distant cousin
the switch nintendo today had a direct
mini unveiling a slew of games releasing
in the coming months many of those
announced are older titles that are
finally making their way to the handheld
such as portal 1 and 2 as a part of the
companion collection out today on switch
as well as persona 3 foof as well as
persona 3
3 through as well as persona 3 through 5
previously announced for xbox game pass
and steam with the most recent entry
landing on october 21st the day before
persona 5 royals release on the console
switch players will be able to get their
hands on mario plus rabbids sparks of
hope the sequel to the tactics game
kingdom battle developed by ubisoft the
direct showed off the game's new
mechanics ditching the first entry's
grid-based movement for a radial limit
as well as the fact that bowser will be
a playable character there were a slew
of other announcements like the factor
demo of the hd2d remake of live alive a
game previously only available in japan
dropped on the eshop today and new
gameplay including our first look at
sonic frontiers on switch if you want to
check out the best trailers from the
direct or see the presentation in its
entirety both videos are available right
here on gamespot
what's that
well i believe it's london calling in it
i'm i'm english i i get to do the accent
fallout london a mod that completely
overhauls bethesda's fallout 4 to tell a
brand new story set 50 years before the
events of the game is slated for release
in 2023
if that didn't sound ambitious enough
colin baker and sylvester mccoy the
actors behind the sixth and seventh
doctors respectively from the very
british tv show doctor who have been
brought on to voice characters
the reveal trailer showed how the
modders have completely converted
fallout 4's boston into a
post-apocalyptic london including iconic
landmarks robots and top hats and plenty
of rain which
accurate considering that another
fallout installment won't be coming from
the team at bethesda until after both
starfield and the next elder scrolls
fallout london might be one of the few
ways to get your single player rad fix
for a very long time and that's it for
today's stories remember to check out
all our nintendo direct coverage while
you count down the minutes until your
steam deck order notification
[Music]